hey guys dr. Berg here in this video I'm going
to show you the absolute fastest way to knock
out back pain within a few minutes so check
this out so what you're going to do is you're
not going to work on the back you're going to
work on the opposite the front part so let's
just pretend that her back pain is right in the
lower part of the right where her pants comes up
that her belt okay if we draw a line to the front
part but we press on the exact opposite side your
belly button is right here so it's just below the
bed line I press into this point what's going to
happen it's going to relieve the back over here
now the use of secret the secret is you have
to match wherever the back pain is just pretend
there's a line going right through her body okay
and sometimes it's like a broad area in the back
so you might want to go this way in that way and
what I like to do is use a massage to what I'm
doing this myself I would use a massage tool to
press into these spots so what you're going to do
is like sometimes the pain is over to this side
then we just shift over and we press into it or
if it's on this side you press on this side what's
fascinating it's always going to be very very
very tender on the front part that's opposing
the back part pain and that's how you know you hit
the right spot what you're going to do is going to
feel around to the epicenter of where it hurts
now I can already feel this is the spot that's
the most tight on her which is probably the most
tender is it yeah and so I'm going to just massage
this for a little bit less than 30 seconds and all
that back pain is going away now two things going
to happen either the pain is going to go away
and you might have to do this several times or
it's going to keep coming back in which case that
you have to look deeper into it could be a disc
problem it could be other things but this is the
fastest way to knock out back pain that I know and
by working in the opposite side no one does this
they work on the back they don't work on the front
all these muscles will melt the lower back okay so
go ahead and try this and put your comments below